is that actually a young Harrison Ford
in the Indiana Jones and the dial of
Destiny trailer no but it's what the
filmmakers want you to think while the
effects may not be fooling viewers just
yet it does seem to be wowing them
Disney and lucasfilm have finally
unveiled the first long-awaited trailer
for Indiana Jones 5. now officially
titled Indiana Jones in the dial of
Destiny this brief glimpse of the film
carries an impressive amount of
emotional weight and narrative reverence
leaning into the film's Bittersweet
promise of a final send-off for one of
Cinema's most iconic Heroes those days
of come and gone all viewers found
plenty to go over in terms of references
to previous entries in the series some
fans were quick to focus on the first
look at the movie's de-aging technology
previous reports had confirmed that the
new film's major flashback scenes with
D.H Harrison Ford but now fans have
actually seen the footage and they can't
stop talking about it normally it's an
ominous sign when viewers have strong
opinions about anything CGI related take
for example She-Hulk but in this case
the response seems to be surprisingly
positive quite a few fans took to
Twitter to Marvel at how well the d8
shots of the actor look one wrote the
de-aging technology has come a long way
Indy appears to have done it the best
another raved they freaking mastered
that de-aging technology didn't I I
truly hope this lives up to the
expectations not that you can do wrong
with director James Mangold on board in
an interview with Empire Ford called the
D aging technology spooky because of how
well it recreates his youthful looks a
fan on Twitter pivoted off his comment
saying Harrison Ford wasn't kidding when
he said Indy 5 has the best the Aging
Tech even fans who admitted being
apprehensive about the movie had to hand
it to the effects one wrote I was
skeptical but this looks so good in the
de-aging technology is getting better
and better another stated bluntly not
really very excited for this movie but
the D aging Tech they've used is pretty
amazing at first glance yet another
Twitter user grabbed to still affords
dhace and wrote wow the Dagen on
Harrison Ford in the shot from the new
Indiana Jones trailer is absolutely
spectacular Indiana Jones and the dial
of Destiny is of course not the first
time Disney has used technology to
digitally create a young version of an
actor recent entries in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe including Captain
Marvel and black widow have used similar
technology for scenes set in the past
and a youthful version of Mark Hamill's
Luke Skywalker has appeared in the
Mandalorian and Star Wars the rise of
Skywalker some fans couldn't help but
compare previous uses of the effects to
what's in dial of Destiny one wrote It's
not Samuel L Jackson kind of the agent
in Captain Marvel but it's still
impressive thank you viewers are
certainly welcome to their opinions of
the best use of de-aging effects but the
technology itself is clearly advancing
Empire notes that the new Indiana Jones
film takes advantage of state-of-the-art
industrial Light and Magic software
which uses archival footage to
accurately render a more youthful
version of a subject's face this
technique is a far cry from instances
like the portrayal of Luke in the book
of vocal fats which digitally
superimposed the CGI version of hamel's
face on a body double lucasfilm
president Kathleen Kennedy explains my
hope is that although it will be talked
about in terms of Technology you just
watch it and go oh my God they just
found footage this was a thing they shot
40 years ago
[Music]